Steve Rogers beard may have been the
talk of the internet after the infinity
war trailer dropped but it was those
gauntlets he's wearing that really got
me intrigued and I know a lot of you
guys were excited about them too
yippee-ki-yay movie lovers it's Jan here
and today I'm examining the clues and
the infinity war trailer and the comics
to reveal what kind of shield we can
expect to see cap hues and Avengers
infinity war and I think you're going to
be pretty psyched about his cool upgrade
just before I get into that if this is
your first time here I do regular comic
book movie and Theory videos and today
I'm kicking off a new round of my
superhero giveaway for all my
subscribers and explain the details and
reveal the winner of the first giveaway
later in this video ok so going into
Avengers infinity war we need to
remember that last time Captain America
had his shield was during his bitter
showdown with Iron Man at the end of
civil war Tony Stark who felt betrayed
that Steve Rogers covered up the fact
the Winter Soldier murdered his parents
angrily told Steve shield didn't belong
to him and that he didn't deserve it
anymore
cap abandoned the shield and went on the
run after that and I think an infinity
war will see cap operating without a
shield for a little while for example he
doesn't seem to have won here when he
catches Proxima midnight sphere and he's
just using his fists against this
outrider however in that epic shot of
cap leading the charge in Wakanda we can
see he's acquired some cool new arm
gauntlets which are a big clue to his
new shield the color and style of caps
new arm shields and the fact they have
what looked like claws on them indicate
they're some cool new tech made in
Wakanda in fact unlike the MCU where
it's Tony's father Howard Stark who made
cap shield in a number of Marvel Comics
it's actually black panther who provides
cap with his shield but although it's
T'Challa who says the awesome line get
this man of shields an infinity war I
think it will be his sister Shuri who
will be the person responsible for caps
new arm shields why do I think this well
because she's a genius who spent many
years researching vibranium and
developing technology and Kevin Feige
said she runs the entire work and and
design group also if you look back at
the black panther trailers you'll see
sure he's sporting some pretty fierce
vibranium based weaponry on her own arms
in the former two Panther star blasters
that she developed herself in fact I
wonder if that smart
and tech we see on caps arms could make
a shield materialize in a similar way to
how Black Panther suit appears here in
his first solo film or similar to the
hard light shielding we've seen Black
Panther used in the comics if this
happens it wouldn't be the first time
we've seen an energy shield on screen in
one of Marvel's properties in the TV
show agents of shield Coulson can
activate an energy shield using his
prosthetic hand and in the animation
next Avengers heroes of tomorrow
Captain America and Black Widow son
James Rogers used an energy shield
designed by Tony Stark as the cap
himself he's used various energy shields
in the comics in the mid 90s Sharon
Carter gave him an experimental plasma
shield which was activated from his
wrist and could repel small arms fire a
couple of years later in the comics
Carter gave Rogers a glove which could
project a photon force field this
photonic shield simulated a vibranium
matrix so it could store and reflect
energy back to an enemy in other
versions as well as defensive properties
the shield also offered possibilities
for attack and it's been able to fire
energy blasts as well as transform into
weapons one of the cool things we've
seen on screen is how cap has thrown his
shield around using magnetic elements to
call it back we might not get that from
a new shield but in the comics later
versions such as a zero point energy
shield can be thrown it's an enemy and
then upon impact they disintegrate and
then a new shield can be created from
the energy generator in a matter of
seconds I hope we do still get to see a
version of cap shield that you can throw
as it's given us some memorable moments
so far in the MCU the list of caps
gauntlets in the trailer also makes me
think of the Captain America Steve
Rogers series in those comic books cap
has a triangular shield which can be
split into two parts so you can attack a
body with one half and still protect
himself with the other and it also has
an energy blade which can be used to cut
through things so why do I think this
could be the basis for CAPS new shield
in infinity war well if you look closely
at this epic team shot in Wakanda
you can see that caps gauntlets have a
triangular shape to them and there are
also several claws which could be used
for cutting like in the comics and given
he's got two arm gauntlets and he's a
makanda the home of all things super
high-tech this makes me think that those
two objects on his arms could likely
transform into a shield a possible
wrinkle in this theory is that in
spider-man homecoming when happy Hogan
was arranging the move of tech from the
Avengers tower
he mentioned a prototype of Captain
America's new shield I still think that
caps new arm shields do look work andin
so I wonder if the new shield that Tony
made will actually end up in the hands
of Bucky Barnes either in infinity war
or in Avengers 4 in the comics Bucky
does take on the mantle of Captain
America and there was already a nod to
that when the Winter Soldier quote cap
shield and the second Captain America
solo movie if you've seen my infinity
war trailer breakdown video then you'll
know that we see Tony Stark holding a
small phone that looks like the same one
cap had FedEx to him at the end of civil
war which means we'll likely see a
reunion between Tony and Steve at some
point in infinity war or Avengers for
now what kind of shield do you think cap
will get an infinity war or do you think
the trailers misleading us and it's
actually Bucky who will get the shield
and are you worried that it's cap who
Tony Stark is crying over in this
cryptic shot in the trailer be sure to
leave me a comment with your thoughts
and subscribe for your chance to win a
cool superhero Funko pop the winner from
the first round of my infinity war
giveaway is on the screen here so make
sure you send me a private message with
your details so I can get the price sent
out to you if you enjoyed this don't
forget to hit that like button and if
you haven't seen it check out my
breakdown of the new infinity war Hulk
Buster Thor and soulstone leaked scenes
by tapping the screen here thanks for
watching and see you next time
yippee-ki-yay movie lovers